Narrator: For this scene in "Coco,"
Pixar's computer kept
getting Mamá Imelda's skirt
caught between her skeleton joints.
So Pixar developed a whole
new simulation system
and digitally wrapped every joint
with a layer of invisible fabric.
Every single Pixar movie
has pushed the boundaries
of 3D animation with
detailed work like this,
from lighting food with two light sources
to simulating realistic fur.
Let's pick up where we
left off in part one,
with Merida's realistic-looking
locks in "Brave."
Merida had a lot of hair.
If you unwound a strand of it,
it would measure 4 feet in length.
But the simulation tech hadn't yet tackled
the unique physics of curly hair,
where each curl has a springlike structure
but the overall movement of
the hair is light and soft
in a way that seems to defy gravity.
Pixar's first step was to
build Merida's hair in layers,
each with a different tightness of curl
to get that natural-looking variation.
The team then spent three years
developing a special simulator called Taz
that'd be powerful enough to handle
the 1,500 hand-placed
curls on Merida's head.
Taz accounted for all the interactions
between different strands
while making sure that
every curl held its shape.
The system also changed
the effect of gravity on Merida's hair,
using a gravity coefficient
closer to the one on the moon
than the one on Earth.
With a lower gravity, the
hair could keep its mass
but flow and bounce in a natural way.
To give the hair its softness,
the lighting team used a mix
of subsurface scattering
and colored shadows
to imitate the complex way
curly hair scatters and transmits light.
It took two months just to
nail the hair in this scene,
when Merida pulls back her hood
to reveal the full volume of curls.
But that work set the stage for Pixar
to represent all hair textures
on screen in the future.
In "Cars," Pixar used ray
tracing in small doses
to create reflections and shadows
in dynamic scenes with
lots of shiny vehicles.
But for the vast majority of shots,
Pixar's artists still built reflections
and mapped out shadows by hand.
That changed with "Monsters University."
The lighting team wanted more time
to focus on the artistic,
rather than the engineering,
side of lighting,
like creating new "scare lights"
for scary monster scenes.
To streamline the process,
the goal was to ray-trace
pretty much everything:
all the shadows and light refractions,
even the reflections in a character's eye.
This required an overhaul
of the lighting system
the studio had used since
the first "Toy Story."
Pixar built a new system
called Global Illumination
that modeled the natural
distribution of light in a scene,
all based on real-world physics.
Now, every time an artist
placed a light source in a shot,
the computer would know
how that light would travel
and interact with other elements,
and it would simulate the
resulting bright spots,
shadows, and reflections.
Global Illumination became
the default lighting system
for every Pixar movie,
making Pixar's light
more closely resemble the
kind we see in real life.
But this model didn't account
for more fantastical scenarios,
like we'd see in "Inside Out."
Joy, the main character of "Inside Out,"
is supposed to resemble a star.
She's made up of glowing particles
that radiate off her skin.
This character had to shed
warm yellow-blue light
wherever she appeared in a scene,
and the light had to track
with her bouncy movement,
which wasn't easy, since she's
literally a ball of energy.
So Pixar's RenderMan team
came up with an effect
they called geometric
area lights, or geolight.
This tool allowed lighting artists
to select a character model
and turn it into a mobile light source.
That way, Joy's light
could travel with her.
If she walks up to a prop,
she projects her glow on it,
and she casts light onto
other characters, too,
like this pivotal scene with Sadness.
Her light was also accurate
to her body structure.
For example, when she picks something up,
we see the light emanate
through her fingers.
This made the outward
glow look more believable,
taking Pixar's lighting system
yet another step forward.
Nature plays a bigger role
in "The Good Dinosaur"
than in any other Pixar film,
so the filmmakers really
needed to nail the landscape
of the American Northwest.
They were especially focused
on the huge, constantly changing clouds
they observed on a research trip.
Traditionally, Pixar movies
used matte-painted clouds,
meaning the artist would paint clouds
onto background plates.
But "The Good Dinosaur"
took place entirely outside,
with clouds in almost every scene.
So they decided for the first time
to create entirely volumetric clouds.
That meant these clouds were 3D objects
animators could move around,
like a character or a key set piece.
But unlike a character or set,
a volumetric object
has no defined surface.
It's just made up of
billions of tiny particles.
The clouds team built a huge library
of what they called "cloud Lego parts."
They joined these
volumetric forms together
to create huge clouds of every type:
rain clouds, stratus
clouds, and cumulus clouds.
With the clouds actually in the scene,
viewers can move in
and around the 3D forms
as the camera moves,
making this world that
much more immersive.
Hank from "Finding Dory" was
"probably the hardest thing"
Pixar had ever animated at that point,
according to Michael Stocker,
the supervising animator on the film.
He definitely wouldn't have
been possible in "Finding Nemo."
Most four- or two-legged
characters, like humans,
have joints and defined
limits to their movement,
but octopi don't have skeletons
or any clear structure to how they move.
To capture that extreme flexibility,
Pixar had to rethink its whole approach
to character construction.
This started with Hank's rig,
the basic puppet that animators use
to control the character's movement.
While humans have clearly
defined elbows that bend,
Hank's elbow had to travel
down the length of his tentacle,
so Pixar's engineers
developed a special rig
that used a cylinder as Hank's elbow
and relied on a special curve function
to dictate how that muscle should move.
This let animators stay faithful
to that key rolling motion
of octopus tentacles.
The filmmakers also needed
the webbing between Hank's tentacles
to flatten and spread
out with each movement,
so the character team
created a new control
to set the depth of the webbing.
This helped give Hank the
squishy-squashy motion
that you see here, and it allowed Pixar
to give life to its most
complex character to date.
The filmmakers behind
the third "Cars" movie
wanted to emphasize the aging
details on hero characters,
like the older racer Louise Nash.
Any car's surface is
composed of multiple layers:
metal flake paint with a clear coating,
car stickers, dirt, grime,
and mud composited on top.
But traditionally, when
Pixar showed an object
with detailed texture
from a more distant shot,
all the little details would
merge into a single pixel,
making the object's
surface look too smooth.
So Pixar developed a technology
called bump roughness mapping,
which converts what
looks like bumps up close
into surface roughness
in farther-away shots.
Louise, for example,
keeps the texture of her
clear-coat scratches,
even in medium and wide shots.
And this tech wasn't only
applicable to "Cars."
Pixar could use the bump-roughness method
to preserve details on
all kinds of 3D objects,
as we'll see for "Incredibles 2."
Clothing simulation was always going
to be a big undertaking in "Coco."
The movie demanded more cloth
than any other Pixar feature,
and many scenes would
involve a lot of movement.
On top of this,
the characters weren't
just humans, but skeletons.
Bones have all these crevices
where clothes can bunch up
and collide with each other,
creating too many collisions
for Pixar's simulator Fizt to handle.
So the studio spent three years
creating a new continuous
collision detection program,
which helped the computer
automatically resolve issues
like cloth bunching up
around a skeleton's hand
or snagging on a bony knee.
Animators also digitally
wrapped the skeletons' joints
with super-stretchy invisible material,
so that when the bones separated,
the pants would touch
that invisible barrier
and not fall into the gaps.
This was a creative solution
to a unique problem,
but it laid the groundwork
for even more advanced
cloth simulation later on.
Fashion was also a big
part of "The Incredibles,"
but in the first movie,
the characters' suits
weren't actual clothing.
They were patterns shaded
onto the characters' bodies,
which is why, in some shots,
the fabric behaves more like skin
and the Incredibles logo stretches out
in unrealistic ways.
For the second movie,
the filmmakers wanted their
clothing to work better
with the extreme movements of
characters like Elastigirl.
That began with constructing
actual digital garments
that sat on top of the characters' skin,
like normal clothing.
The next key step
was manipulating UV
coordinates on the clothes.
In "Incredibles 2," a
tech called 3D UV-scaling
preserved the details of a cloth
when stretched or compressed.
Pixar also found a way to
use bump roughness mapping,
the technology from "Cars 3,"
to keep very fine
illuminated details intact,
even when Elastigirl extended
her body to wild proportions.
That made it possible for Elastigirl
to get a brand-new suit,
this iridescent unitard
that keeps its subtle shimmery texture
through all the hyper-flexible movements.
Compare that to this shot
of Elastigirl stretching out
in the first "Incredibles."
The surface of her new suit
looks much more like actual fabric.
You can see how Pixar
has stretched the limits
of what its cloth technology can do.
The fourth "Toy Story"
brought up issues of scale,
thanks to all the scenes
set in the antique store,
and thus all the toys.
There were over 10,000
antiques in this store,
and Pixar had to find a way
to program each and every one
with varying levels of wear and tear.
Animators tackled this challenge
by assigning three different
ages to the antiques:
fairly new, moderately
aged, and extremely aged.
The computer than gave
the items surface details
that fit those ages, from
micro-scratches on china platters
to wear and tear on old rugs.
The ability to add detail
to so many different objects
is what gave the world of "Toy Story 4"
its visual complexity and appeal.
Pixar has had its share
of unique characters,
but Dad from "Onward" is made
up of only a pair of legs.
The rest of his body is just stuffing
with a sweatshirt, vest,
and gloves thrown over it,
which made it difficult to animate.
Dad's legs could be rigged and animated
like a traditional character,
using reference footage filmed
in front of a green screen.
But his upper half had no skin
or structure underneath it,
so it called for simulation,
not animation, in many shots.
The arms, for example,
just had to flop around,
a movement that's more
believable when simulated.
So the filmmakers developed
a hybrid simulation-animation rig for Dad.
With this rig,
animators could manipulate
Dad's lower half
like they usually would,
but the simulation team controlled
everything above the belt when needed.
The movement of Dad's stuffing
was based on a volumetric sim,
a simulation for something with volume,
while the clothes on top of the stuffing
were largely controlled with
standard cloth simulation.
Pixar also improved the interaction
between volumetric sims and cloth sims
so that if you pushed on Dad's clothing,
the stuffing would get
squished believably,
and vice versa, if you
pushed on the stuffing,
the clothing would move out of the way.
The hybrid rig improved the relationship
between separate
simulations, and ultimately,
it showed how simulation and
animation could join forces
to create realistic movement
on an unrealistic character.
Pixar needed to make
its musician characters
play instruments, most notably Joe,
who had to go through the
complicated, rapid motions
of playing the piano.
At first, the team tried to use simulation
to handle the interactions
between Joe's fingers and the keys,
relying on a collision system
like the one used for the cloth in "Coco."
But the collision system didn't work,
because Joe's fingers were too heavy
for the computer's piano keys.
So instead of simulating the movement,
character technical director Jason Davies
developed what he called
a finger contact rig.
When one of Joe's fingers
pushed down on a key,
the rig would calculate the correct angle
for the key to rotate,
so it looked like Joe was pushing it.
The modeling and rigging teams
also gave Joe's hand 292 controls,
including variables
they'd never used before,
even adding a control for each tendon
to convey the tension in
Joe's hand as he played.
This level of hand and wrist
control made his performances
look passionate and convincing on screen,
with a level of realism
that pushed the boundaries
of human movement in animation.
"Luca" is a coming-of-age story
about a sea monster who
can transform into a human,
and the filmmakers needed
to show this transformation
in a fluid way.
They also wanted to
give animators the power
to dictate all the details of that change,
such as where the transformation begins
and the speed at which it happens.
Before, adjustments to
those kinds of details
would have to go through animation,
then go to the effects team,
and only then would animators get to see
how it all looked after rendering.
But for "Luca," they created
a transformation rig,
so animators could fine-tune
the different aspects
of the change one by one
and see the result right
there in front of them.
That way, they could
perfectly time the transition
from the layers of
changes in the human skin
to the flipping scales and octopus spots
in the sea-monster skin.
This was a new way
to streamline the whole production process
and put more artistic control
in the hands of animators.
After all, Pixar views
technology first and foremost
as a storytelling tool.
Whether creating a new kind of light
to better convey a character's emotions
or rethinking cloud models
to give audiences a
stronger sense of place,
Pixar's technical innovations
have always served its stories first,
and that's the key to the studio's record
of creating both
groundbreaking innovations
and beloved movies.